This is a really unusual thing more than anything
the other day. Eric Trump, one of Donald Trump's
kids, went on Fox News and he said he was
part of the LGBTQ community, something which
certainly has not been made public, if indeed
it's what he was trying to say. And initially,
the speculation was either Eric misspoke,
there was some weird grammatical ambiguity
or he's saying he's bisexual, I guess. Let's
take a look at the video clip. The content
is from Fox and Friends in a segment about
supposed LGBTQ Trump supporters.
Take a look at in The New York Times. And
toxicants. This her. Her name is Chris. She
doesn't want to give her last name because
she says that her colleagues at work, it wouldn't
go well with them. She lives in Manhattan.
She's in her 50s. Secret Trump voter. That's
right. She is. She's gay. She said her four
one K went up with your dad. Nineteen point
six percent. Gas prices better than they were
under Obama. She goes on to say that Obamacare
was five hundred and sixty dollars a month
for her and she had lost her job. So she was
priced out. She talks about crime in the neighborhood.
She talks about Bill de Blasio and how he's
inept that the Russia Trump Russia thing,
that Clinton's fingerprints are all over it.
She calls Joe Biden weak. Is this. But she
doesn't want to use her last name. And there
are a lot of people that might be voting for
your dad that aren't admitting it.
And it was Bret Stephens who's been a critic
of your dad, who wrote the editorial.
So are you counting on this person on the
secret voter?
Ainslee, that person's there. I'm telling
you, I see it every day. The LGBT community,
they are incredible. And you should see how
they come out in full force from my father
every single day. I'm part of that community
and we love the man. And thank you for protecting
our neighborhoods and thank you for it. For
protecting our cities.
Yeah. So. So Eric Trump says he's part of
that community. Now, either he's saying he's
bisexual, I guess, or it's some kind of grammatical
vagary. He met something else. If we put the
actual word for word, quote, up on the screen,
what he said was the LGBT community. They
are incredible. And you should see how they've
come out in full force for my father every
single day. I'm part of that community and
we love the man. So it does seem that Eric
Trump is saying he is a member of the LGBT
community that comes out for his dad. I was
thinking, is there any other way you could
pass the grammar? And I guess you could maybe
say it was an inarticulate way of Eric Trump
saying that he's part of the community that
hosts people who come out to support Trump
and that he has been part of hosting LGBT
community member. It would be a very weird
grammatical structure for a native English
speaker, but I didn't know what to make of
it. Of course, if Eric Trump were bisexual,
I would have no issue with it whatsoever.
But it sort of seemed odd. Now, he put out
a statement eventually clarifying. But before
we get to the statement, is it possible that
the explanation here is, remember, Eric Trump
is not known as, you know. The smart one necessarily.
Is it possible Eric Trump didn't know what
LGBT meant, like he thought, you know, it's
it's the I w e w union and it's the Teamsters
and it's LGBT. It like is it actually possible
that Eric Trump didn't know what LGBT meant?
And he was just like, yeah, I'm part of it.
I'm part of it. Any group that supports Trump,
I'm actually a part of. Is he possibly that
dumb? I don't know. But Eric Trump has now
backtracked. Eric Trump put out a statement
to The New York Post saying, to clarify, many
of our close friends are part of the LGBT
community, which was the intent of my statement.
The left has taken that vote for granted for
a long time. And support from the gay community
for my father is incredible. As to me personally,
as I think, you know, I am happily married.
I am a happily married man to my wife, Lara.
So I still think it's possible that in the
moment he would have you give him any four
letters, you know, ABC or G.H. Y que whatever
he would have said. He listen. They support
Trump. I'm part of the community. It's all
great. Maybe he really didn't know what it
meant. It's all just very weird. And you couldn't
script a more bizarre reelection campaign
if
you tried.